les puedo asegurar que
que dios nos habla
no sé a lo que ustedes llamen dios pero
hacer a la fuerza la deidad la energía
en lo que ustedes vuelque en su
espiritualidad cuando les digo que dijo
nos habla a lo afirmo y estoy convencido
que nosotros tenemos que aprender a
detectarlo a escucharlo a saber
encontrarlo
hace algunos años estaba en buenos aires
acompañando a un amigo cantante ha
gustado cordera en una rueda de prensa
cuando el arrancado a su carrera solista
y en esa rueda de prensa llegamos a la
metro a la radio un capital al programa
de andy kusnetzoff a la mañana se vivió
un gran momento de radio para mí estar
ahí es siempre aprender siempre
encontrarme con colegas un momento de
conectarme con lo que hago con lo que
vamos a hacer y fue un gran momento
cuando terminó la entrevista que iba a
durar 15 minutos y duró como una hora el
conductor del programa andy sostenía que
era un gran asador y cada noche teníamos
que ir a comer a la casa que había que
seguir el momento cuando uno quiere
mantener eternos esos momentos mágicos
nosotros dijimos sí sí sí teníamos un
gran día de trabajo por delante y
seguimos el derrotero por diferentes
medios y canales de televisión
a la tarde sentados esperando una
reunión eran las 6 de la tarde la última
reunión a las 7 de la tarde
en esas tardes de marzo en las que en
buenos aires el calor del verano aún
afecta nos sentamos en la vereda
cansadísimos diciendo vamos a suspender
el tema del alzado no no estamos en
condiciones de soportar un asado de
mañana a la mañana a madrugar avisarle
andy el pelado en usaba celular en esa
época que no vamos a ir a la casa sacó
el celular lo busco le estoy empezando a
escribir y aparece andy con carnes con
cortes de asado achuras provoletas todas
cosas ricas para comer dice que bueno
que los encuentro vivo acá cerca a las
nueve los estoy esperando tiene coche a
no se acordaba mi nombre anota la
dirección tiki tiki tiki tiki se va nos
miramos y decimos tenemos que ir tuvimos
la reunión reacomodamos la energía y a
la nueva de noche llegamos a un lugar
increíble un lugar en la que la parrilla
estaba lista para
con el fuego prendido con los cortes de
carne puestos había una picada algo para
tomar nos miramos menos mal que vinimos
a veces nos pasa eso
estuvo venir y el ayudante de cocina era
justamente manuel lozano manuel lozano
es el fundador del creador de la
fundación sí y de la misión solidaria
que hacen en la radio hace tantos años y
tan conocida en toda la argentina ellos
rápidamente se conectaron con ese tema
que los une y encontrarle al pelado
todos los logros que habían tenido desde
la acción solidaria movilizando lo desde
la radio y todo lo que había significado
en sus vidas esa transformación y
meterse en algo que era un tema
desconocido
el 80 y 90 por ciento del tiempo la
atención y la charla iba dirigida a
gustavo y yo como un espectador
aleatorio en este asado y fortuito
estando en una compañía este ocasional
sentí que yo me estaba hablando a mí le
estaban hablando a otra persona pero
ellos me estaban bajando una información
a mí lo tuve claro en ese momento y me
significó varias cosas una poder atender
un conflicto que yo tenía en ese momento
de valorización de mi profesión de mi
capacidad profesional 2 era un llamado a
la acción un grito más que un llamado a
la acción a decir hay que hacer algo
podéis hacer algo tenéis que movilizarse
del lugar que habitas y tercero y en ese
momento no me dio para tanto la el
conocimiento de la conciencia y la
lucidez era enfrentar cantidad de ideas
limitantes que tenía en mi ser
siempre me considere de las personas
optimistas de las positivas las que van
por la avenida de alentar los
emprendimientos de decir va a ir bien
dale hacelo confía en vos creer en
entender que poniendo lo mejor vuelve lo
mejor siempre me sentí de esos de esas
personas que dicen si elegí vivir en
esta ciudad me vine a vivir a necochea
la elegí porque me gustaba el mar el
parque en la playa me gustaba la idea de
en 78 minutos atravesarla y poder estar
presente en una situación personal o
lúdica y rápidamente poder volver al
trabajo me encantaba porque también
estaba todo por hacer vine me establecí
viene con mis cosas y decidí armar una
oficina una oficina en la que iba a
desarrollar publicidad y diseño gráfico
iba a desarrollar eventos de que tengan
que ver con la gastronomía con la música
y posiblemente instalar una fm para todo
esto yo me había formado y todas estas
las actividades que a mí me gustaban y
que realmente me emocionaba y yo sentía
que amaba hacer me encontraba con
personas que contenta decían te vista de
la neurosis y qué bueno y qué vas a
hacer no voy a hacer una revista y
gracián
la revista y gratis la revista tesis o
qué vas a hacer
no pienso por una radio una radio si la
radio de rock porque todo el día rock
que no mezclen éxito no es miguel a
mercancía carne co
así que bueno me miraron cómo estaría
loquito como si tendrían algún problema
de análisis de mercado realmente en el
momento en que dije que queríamos en un
mediano que había una casita armar una
discoteca dicen que en el médano que
está frente al hogar de anciano que
parece abandonado a eso es imposible eso
para pinamar no es para necochea me
encontraba con muchas personas que
decían esta ciudad hay que arar la hay
que empezarla de vuelta por supuesto
estaban las personas que tiraban buena
onda pero aún no le hacen
más peso y más ruido de esas personas
que descaradamente te tiran atrás en el
proyecto o llegas a vivir acá con todos
tus bártulos y rápidamente te dicen no
sopla con lo que ibas a hacer va a ser
un desastre la verdad las tierras tienen
ciudad tendrá esquí por la ruta 11 eso
sinceramente en un momento fue un motor
un motor porque claro pusimos la radio y
en el momento cumple un año la radio
grabamos para todos los que decían que
no iba a funcionar ese motorcito tenía
que ver con responder a esas voces a
esas voces que en ese momento uno se
quedaba escuchando y que replicaban que
acá nos iban a poder hacer las cosas por
suerte las voces no ganaron yo seguí
adelante
fui emprendiendo nuevos proyectos no
deje de capacitarme no deje de rodearme
de buenos equipos de trabajo y el éxito
en los términos que lo conocemos fue
llegando a los resultados si hablamos de
los económicos
hablamos de bueno de uno puede
divertirse de vacaciones tener su auto
tener una estabilidad comprar una casa
los éxitos de reconocimiento que tienen
que ver con decir bueno con la radio
logramos que tal artista nos dé una nota
porque no sucedía no era tan habitual
que un artista de alcance nacional desde
una radio del interior una nota con las
bandas pudimos traer a tal banda pudimos
tratar bandita pudimos traer a tal banda
y los logros se van sucediendo y también
los logros de programación de
planificación cuando programamos algo
decíamos bueno alcanzamos las metas la
verdad que
necochea es un lugar del cual muy
agradecido porque los oyentes y las
personas que a las que le propuesta
respondieron siempre muy bien pero
dentro mío existía una especie de vacío
porque la alegría la alegría que duraba
cada logro se iba como desvaneciendo
realmente fue pasando a través de los
años y hablo de esa crisis cuando me
encuentro por suerte en ese trazado en
ese encuentro con personas que yo admiro
mucho y que desnudaban lo que les pasaba
en el momento en que lograron hacer lo
que se llamó algo de valor
la idea de realmente darle valor a mis
emprendimientos
a mí me asustaba porque me quedé con la
idea de que sea solidario a ver se puede
hacer algo exitoso pero que de la mano
tenga un valor no es tan común se puede
hacer algo de valor pero que sea exitoso
tampoco es como uno sea realmente es es
muy difícil hermanar éxito y un valor un
valor adicional de una profundidad a una
actividad para mí la solidaridad siempre
era un tema me parecía que había gato
encerrado me parecía que las personas
que publicitaban su solidaridad se
hacían las bonitas que realmente el
estado tenía que encargarse de las
personas que tenían necesidades
eran todas las palabras y todas las
construcciones que yo tenía adentro
cuando yo me vuelvo de ese viaje digo
tenemos que hacer algo con la radio
tenemos una masa muy grande de oyentes y
realmente podemos ayudar pero para mí
transformar desdecirme de muchos años
debe ser una radio de rock de siempre
tener la idea más más más picante de la
salida más irónica
de tratar determinadas temáticas con
determinada banalidad que significaba
desdecirme que significaba realmente
reconstruir esa identidad que tenía de
mí mismo y fundamentalmente y que en ese
momento me pensaba que los demás tengan
de mí porque era un lugar al que yo
había tenido como resultado el éxito
pero no eran un éxito que realmente a mí
me hacía sentir ya vacío
esto no se resolvió en 500 km volviendo
de buenos aires para que pueda es ese
brote citó pueda salir pasó como un año
y medio y en ese año y medio ausencia
como abuelo de la solidaridad como hago
lo de la solidaridad y en el medio de
todo esa crisis que cuando es laboral
muchas veces es personal buscando y
ahondando en lo personal llegó una frase
llegó una frase que me resonó que fue
amar o reclamar esa frase realmente para
mí fue una muletilla para poder ir
adelante pero fue una revelación soy de
jugar con las palabras pero en el
momento en el que entendí que dentro del
reclamo estaba la palabra amar entendí
que
el conflicto habitaba dentro mío para
mis relaciones personales con las
situaciones en las que yo me encontraba
en conflicto y también con las
profesionales decir basta a callar esas
voces era una responsabilidad mía la
solución del conflicto estaba dentro mío
y fundamentalmente fue terrible cuando
descubrí que yo respecto a todo lo que
significaba solidaridad podía hacer como
esas personas que me decían que en un
médano no va a funcionar una discoteca
que una radio de rock no va a funcionar
nada más que desde otro lugar yo tenía
mi propio que hong mi propio criticón
eran mis propios pisa brotes no hacía
falta que nadie venga a decírmelo y eso
de eso se trata un poco esta charla de
que nosotros mismos somos los que nos
limitamos para poder hacer la acción de
actitud solidaria tuve que amar y hoy me
decían vas a hablar de amor y yo digo
todo el samur pero el amor nos da eso de
que en medio uno alocado lo dice todo si
estaba enamorado y qué sistema fiesta
brasil y como yo no sé a dedo a verla
estaba enamorado
y tiene esa cosa irracional es como una
locura
y de alguna forma para mí fue así como
un salto un salto al vacío
de repente decir bueno vamos a hacer en
este despertar solidario una acción que
dejemos de reclamar para empezar a amar
de esa forma empezamos a construir
actitud solidaria actitud solidaria se
hace desde la radio pero lo primero que
detectamos era que necesitábamos primero
pedir ayuda teníamos que ir a pedirle
colaboradores que necesitábamos una mano
ya no ser
autosuficientes como estábamos
acostumbrados a hacer cuando hablo en
plural es porque su solidario estamos un
montón de personas y realmente
tendríamos que ir a otras radios a otros
medios de comunicación es decir 6 por
favor me desistas gacetilla de prensa-
cuando hasta hace dos años tal vez
nosotros decidimos y leíamos son una
gacetilla de prensa-
tuvimos que realmente entregarnos
arremangarnos y decir a ver la
cooperadora del hospital porque
necesitamos transparencia dicen y
sentarme con las chicas de la
cooperadora queda para mí en ese momento
eran como unas señoras medias que
estaban
con mucho tiempo libre dicen bueno como
tienen tiempo libre para ayudarnos podía
visualizar profundamente lo que hacen en
lo que generan eso es amar o reclamar
eso es encontrar dentro de uno mismo
la limitación actitud solidaria en esa
primera ese primer año nos
revolucionó la ayuda de los
colaboradores fue desbordante la gente
rápidamente dijo si les damos una mano y
si desea pensar que todas esas voces que
tenía dentro que decían ahora van a
decir que se hacen los buenos a mira
esto que el hijo se estaba de la
realidad lleva cinco años actitud
solidaria les podría hablar horas de
todo lo que significa de todo lo que
hacemos los resultados tienen que ver
con cosas concretas tienen que ver con
que durante cinco años asistimos a entre
9 y 16 hogares que trabajan acá en
necochea que están a metros de donde
pasamos a diario y recibieron juguetes
ropa comida en diferentes cantidades y
por supuesto todo el apoyo que podamos
tener nosotros descubrimos realidades en
necochea y chicos que no conocen el mar
no estoy exagerando les estoy diciendo
no conocer el mar y ustedes se pueden
preguntar pero che cómo puede ser que no
conozca el mar la respuesta que yo tengo
es no tienen un adulto que los acompañe
a ese nivel estamos hablando se puede
hacer cosas muy simples no hace falta
armar un evento enorme y mega popular
con solo hacer un acto le cambian la
vida a una persona y eso tiene que ver
con amar o reclamar en números todo el
dinero recaudado a la cooperadora del
hospital se terminó la sala de guardia
pediátrica que se separó de la guardia
general vos iba con un nene con
broncoespasmos y estabas en la misma
guardia donde entraba un accidente de
tránsito este término sea guardia se
ayudó con la sala 2 de internación
general se terminó se hicieron reformas
en internación pediátrica que era un
lugar que yo no sabía que existía en el
primer piso donde realmente había muchas
necesidades se compró aparatología este
año y sobra dinero para lo que es un
próximo emprendimiento que sería una
sala de estimulación temprana cuantas
cosas aparte de tener más de 350
voluntarios que laburan adhonorem para
cortar las calles para ayudar para armar
stands para hacer cantidad de cosas qué
significa ese evento y todo eso surgió y
todo eso volvió sencillamente porque
tener un cambio de actitud profundo pero
un simple cambio de actitud
todo eso es un ejército de personas que
en abril dicen acá estamos para ayudar
que hay que hacer en abril todavía no
sabemos qué pedirles y en julio
realmente funciona cada vez mejor
actitud solidaria se transforma ahora en
una ong porque hay personas que todo el
año tienen ganas de quizás sin tanta
exposición y que todos nos enteremos de
estar ayudando y acompañando en
realidades
acá realmente yo no vengo a hablarles de
que tengan su idea solidaria y entre
todos cambiamos el mundo yo acá vengo a
invitarlos y a decirles que sea cual sea
la actividad que ustedes desarrollan lo
que ustedes hacen realmente desde su
propio lugar
amando o reclamando pueden hacer el
cambio no hace falta para ayudar irse a
jujuy
salvar un nene no si sos contador siendo
contador podés hacer tu cambio amando o
reclamando con tu mujer con tus padres
con tus hermanos con tus hijos se trata
de ser apasionado y amar y decir a ver
tengo un hermano y no hablo por una
diferencia política están cargando se
puede morir mañana che viejo cómo está
te extraño de eso estoy hablando y
también estoy hablando de poder
transformar su realidad profesional en
este caso el regalo para nosotros para
todos los que hacemos la radio fue tener
algo que es exitoso y de valor y no esa
actitud solidaria se redimensionó el
hecho de ir a la radio de hacer
entrevistas de convocar se redimensionó
es distinto el universo que nosotros
habitamos gracias a esto porque logramos
algo y nos sentimos muy afortunados que
es hacer algo exitoso con un valor
gracias por escuchar la pregunta que yo
les quiero dejar en la siguiente si
llegan a escuchar a dios si lo llegan a
detectar si lo llegan a volver a
encontrar porque a cada rato está en un
taxi hace un rato hoy a la mañana me
dijo un amigo estaba en un taxi lo
tienen que saber encontrar les habla
ustedes que le van a decir amar o
reclamar yo mi respuesta es a las
gracias
[Aplausos]